For this programming assignment you needed to create the
variable all purchases and add it to our Yo data
frame. The transform function takes in a data frame and
allows us to add different variables to it by recombining
variables that are already within the data frame. So
here I'll create the variable All Purchases and then I'll
set it equal to the sum of all the yogurt
flavors strawberry, blueberry, pina colda, plain, and mixed berry. When
I run the code, I can see that my number of variables
changed. And, just to be sure, I can print a summary of
this variable as well. You might have also used this code. This
code is fine, it's just a bit more verbose than we need.